I think it is interesting how
men can watch their favorite athletes
compete in all kinds of sports
and cheer for them and be inspired by them,
but when women see other successful women,
we tend to see them as a personal attack on us.
Like, I've never heard of a man watch the NBA
and then complain
that the players are setting unrealistic expectations
of how men should look
and that men should be a certain height.
But when it comes to Hannah from Ballerina Farms,
I get so many comments from people saying, well,
she's setting unrealistic expectations for women.
Like, what does that even mean?
We have this thing in this day and age
where we feel like we are
entitled to look out into the world,
to look on social media,
to look in the regular media,
and see ourselves reflected back to us.
Like, we personally
need to be represented in every area of life.
And if there is a woman
who is doing something different than us,
if she is more successful at us in a certain way,
um, then that is a personal attack on us,
and it is setting unrealistic expectations for us,
and it's just designed to make us feel bad.
And it's such a narcissistic
and just miserable way to view the world.
Like, you don't have to think that way.
It's very freeing to let go of that
and to just let people be successful
and find it interesting.
That some people are born,
you know, seven feet tall and can play in the NBA,
and that's cool,
and I'm not,
and that's okay.